Hello, everybody. Welcome to another episode of
Cutters,
clinicalistic health hour.
Where we're going to be talking about questions that you have.
And we got a bunch of questions that came in.
So we want to get started with those.
And remember, you can chat in your questions as well.
So if you have any questions, go ahead and chat them in.
We have a number to go through.
And double.
We'll get to your chat questions as best we can.
The first question is,
what causes low stomach acid?
This week's live Q&A mentioned
academia and I have been told repeatedly
that I have low higher adenia.
I think that body has trouble absorbing minerals in general.
Okay, so the different types of academia,
many of them can be tied to the HCL deficiency.
So your parietal cells and your stomach make
chrytorchloric acid.
And they do so in the presence of food that is in your stomach.
It also actually does so in the presence of you,
even just starting to chew.
Or actually, even your thinking about eating
causes stomach secretion, stomach cells to create and to create HCL.
Now the problem is, is things that we eat,
chemicals, additives,
flavorings, colorings, poisons, toxins, things like that
can affect that cell production of HCL.
And when we have a decreased production of HCL
that causes probably the most common
primary cause of health conditions in our country.
Because if I don't make it up HCL,
I'm not going to digest my food well.
I'm not going to be able to stimulate intrinsic factor
because it's dependent on HCL production.
So I'm not going to be absorbing B12.
So that can lead to a B12 type adenia.
If I'm not digesting my food properly,
it's going into my small intestine only partially digested.
It's putting a much greater straight on my pancreas
and on my liver production of bile for lipase.
And it can irritate because food is going
into my small intestine only partially digested.
It can irritate my gut lining,
can cause ultimately
gut issues and leaky gut syndrome.
And cause all sorts of health conditions.
So that can lead to just a plethora of health conditions.
One could say you have,
whenever you're trying to treat a patient regardless
of what they have, whether it be cancer
or an autoimmune disease, you have to start with a gut.
So to start with a gut, you have to start with the highest
weight up even in the mouth.
And definitely your basic
health improvement has to start with HCL production.
Now, what do you do to help increase HCL production?
Well, you support your stomach by adding HCL
or an acid like apple cider vinegar to your diet with your meals.
So it takes stress off those parietal cells of the stomach,
those are the cells that bake HCL and your stomach.
So by taking HCL with your meals,
you are taking some stress off your parietal cells,
allowing them to recover or allowing them to be able
to start creating HCL in a better fashion.
So taking HCL, I always suggest taking HCL with digestive enzymes
because if you have HCL production issues,
you have already overstressed your pancreas for a period of time.
So taking pancreatic enzymes with HCL is really the way to go.
So how do you know if your anemia is because of low hydrochloric acid production?
Well, there are signs of hypochloridria.
So hypochloridria is low hyper low hydrochloric acid production.
I've created a video on our blog.
So if you go to our website and just type in hydrochloric acid,
you'll see several blog posts on that and I've created several videos on actually
how that actually happens physiologically and then what to do for correction
and to help support and protect your stomach and help that heal.
So can you know for sure that anemia is caused HCL deficiency?
No, but there are blood tests, even in a standard CBC in complete metabolic
pedal that gives you hits on hypochloridria.
Now that's stated in that video that you'll see on that blog post.
So I'm not going to get into that right now, but you can you can look at
for patterns in your CBC in complete metabolic pedal that will suggest
hypochloridria. That still doesn't say, I mean,
a person can have hypochloridria anidemia and the anemia is not caused from hypochloridria.
So there's different types of anemia and you want to get a differential diagnosis on that.
So if you could have anidemia due to poor absorption of iron,
you could have anemia due to issues with transfer end, which is the enzyme
that transfers iron in your blood. You could have anemia due to B12 deficiency
because you're not consuming enough B12. You could have anemia due to B12 deficiency
because you're not absorbing B12 like I mentioned before. That's you need what's this chemical
that is made in your stomach called intrinsic factor. That's only created when you have HCL
production. So intrinsic factor is needed to absorb B12. You could have an absorption issue
in your gut simply because you have a hyper-inflamed gut. So investigating what the cause of the
inflammation in the gut is from, which is most commonly food sensitivities. We have antibodies
to different foods and you're eating those foods and every time you eat those foods, you're causing
this inflammatory hyperfire in the gut and that's going to decrease absorption of all your nutrients
and certainly iron could be in that category and your B vitamins could be in that category as well.
So you're trying to investigate what is going on. There's also anemia's chronic disease. So if the
person knows that they have cancer or kidney disease or some other chronic disease that can lead
to anemia, then there's anemia due to iron loss. You definitely want to investigate that. Let's say,
well, I don't have cancer. I don't have kidney disease. I'm actually pretty healthy but I just have
this long-standing anemia. You want to look at anemia due to iron loss. So maybe if you're a female,
maybe you're having really heavy periods. You want to investigate that. Look at your hormones
to help balance that. Also, you could have anemia due to iron loss because you have a
slow bleed ulcer. So if you have a duodenal ulcer or a stomach ulcer or a slow bleed, you could
be losing iron that way. So you want to investigate that and the number one cause of that is H-pilora
infections and the number one cause of H-pilora infections is hypochydria. So it kind of all cycles
back to hypochydria in some way, shape or form. Regardless of whether you have, you know, people
we always think there's just this one day that if I just fix that, that everything's going to go away.
Well, most commonly, we have multiple comorbidities going on and you want to try to
to plug the holes in the dam along the way. So I would definitely look at hypochydria,
look at signs in your blood test that can hit towards that. See all those on my video on the blog post
and dealing with digging down to the ultimate cause of the endemia. You don't want to ignore that
because if you have a bleed somewhere that isn't investigated, well, that could be deadly.
Ultimately, a long term that could be from cysts, you know, even ovarian cysts and things
like that. Fibroids are really a common cause of endemia in women. So you want to investigate that.
It's very difficult to take care of a fibroid naturally. You almost always have to do surgery
to remove the fibroid in order to get rid of the endemia. Long term endemia issues are just
going to give you a lot of fatigue, could cause other ill health issues. So you definitely want to
try to dig to get to the bottom of that. Next question came in and said, I'm wondering if you
recommend chlorine dioxide, MMS or CDS or in other forms and it's protocols. So we actually
scrubbed our website from any blog post that we had on MMS because the FDA came down at it so hard.
So when we used to see a lot more line patients and testing them in the clinic and things, they
tested very commonly tested positive for MMS and we used, you know, lower doses of MMS on those patients
with really good success. It can be a good thing to treat acute infections.
Chronic line, typically not. So most chronic line cases, the person is suffering from symptoms
of autoimmune disease, not from current exposure and current infection. Many times people with
chronic line think that, oh, this burrelia is acted up again, it's flared up again and I got to try
to kill it. And then while that can be true, more often than not, it's not the burrelia acted up. The
burrelia is long gone. The burrelia, burlinorathy is the infectious agent number one culprit of
Lyme disease. But it's the what damaged that burrelia did. It got inside the cell, caused your
immune system to try to kill burrelia and kids and can't end up making antibodies against the cell.
So you get it up with self antibodies, aka an autoimmune disease with any type of chronic infection.
And that may be more often than not what is actually causing the patient the symptoms.
So flayer taking place with somebody with a chronic line or chronic viral infection or
that they attribute to a chronic line or chronic viral is actually quite often an autoimmune response.
So it's actually they're getting symptoms of an autoimmune disease. Their body is attacking cell
structure. They feel lousy. They think it's the Lyme acting up and they're trying to use things
like MMS that could kill. So MMS would be a pathogen kill agent. It's not going to heal your body.
It's it's oxidizing and being an oxidizing agent, it's going to kill pathogens.
So just a little bit of understanding about that, everybody's taking a lot of antioxidants. I mean,
that you see in natural circles, everybody needs more antioxidants. And you see an Instagram and
YouTube and TikTok natural doctors talk about take more antioxidants. You need antioxidants in
order of survive because the thought processes that we live in a poisonous world. So we're exposed
to different toxins, micotoxins and heavy metals and pesticides and herbicides and things. These
are oxidizing agents. The problem with oxidizing agents, they're they're poisons. So they can damage
ourselves. They can damage our DNA and they can lead to cancer. So then we take, oh, wow,
I'm ready to take tons of antioxidants. I'm going to take good diet. I'm going to take ALA. I'm
going to take all, you know, I'm going to see I'm going to take all these antioxidants because I don't
want to get this disease. But we have to realize that our body is in has to be in balance. Yes,
oxidizing agents out of balance can cause damage. But our body actually makes oxidizing agents.
Our body will actually create reactive oxygen species in the presence of pathogens. So we're
exposed to a fungus or a bacteria or a virus. We'll actually make an oxidizing agents in order to
kill most things. So by taking high dose antioxidants for a long time, then we can
hinder our body from killing pathogens. Well, in balance, the other way can be a problem too. So
if you're using something like MMS, which is an oxidizing agent because, you know, you read somewhere
that MMS is good for you and you're taking that on a daily basis, well, you could you could be
in balance the other way, especially when we're living in this toxic world and we're exposed to even
more accidents. So we're really oxidizing our tissue that can lead to cell damage that could
lead to damage to your gut cells. I can lead to damage of all your cells that can lead to it gets
absorbed into the cell can lead to DNA damage, which is which causes cancer. So it's all about
balance. So if a person suspects that they have a virus or they suspect a bacterial infection or
they suspect a acute Lyme disease, using an oxidizing agent for a short period of time can be
beneficial to kill it. But it's like anything you have to keep that balance. You don't want to get
out of balance either way. Do I take antioxidants? Yes. Not cut not all the time, though. You should
be pulsing these supplements. So should you take an oxidizing agent? Well, yeah, like I said,
if you think you're exposed to an acute pathogens, that's where taking an oxidizing agent can be helpful.
Actually, using an oxidizing agent to treat cancer can be beneficial. I have cancer
adverse patients that, you know, we'll say, I want to be on glutathione. That was a question
on our Zoom call last week. Should a breast cancer patient be on glutathione all the time? Well,
the answer is, well, no, you know, if I tested them for glutathione, I tested positive for this period
of time, then yes, they should. But if not, you don't just, you know, arbitrarily go on high dose
antioxidants, which glutathione would be to think that that's going to kill cancer. Well,
antioxidants are going to kill cancer. Antioxidants may protect one from cancer, but they're not going
to kill cancer. And in order to kill cancer, your body can be making reactive oxygen species
to do that. Cancer cells themselves are going to be more sensitive to cell death by reactive oxygen
species than healthy cells are. So you don't want to defeat that purpose. That's what keyboard
therapy is. keyboard therapies are an oxidizing agent. So it's killing cancer by oxidizing those
cells. And cancer cells are going to be more susceptible to oxidation and damage and cell
lysis to oxidation than healthy cells going to be because healthy cells produce it its own glutathione
or cancer cells because they're rapid replication are going to be able to produce as much glutathione.
Other question was, do you recommend urine therapy? So urine therapy can be used in
live disease and that's been told to be used in cancer as well. No, I don't necessarily promote
urine therapy. I think we're at the beach a few weeks ago and my son-in-law will say that urine
therapy is used for or what is it? The jellyfish stings that he kindly volunteered to pee on my foot
if I step on a map jellyfish. Good thing I didn't take him up on that. But, you know, if some
practitioners have used that with success, I'm not necessarily against it, but urine, how do people
think that's really gross, but urine should be a void of any bacteria and things that should be
accepted. Next question, how often do you need animals? I don't know if I answered this last week or
not. How often do you need to do animals, coffee animals? Really depends on what your purpose is as far
as your health conditions go. So, currently, I don't do any coffee animals. If I am feeling ill,
in a way that I feel like the cancer is raising its ugly head again, which was a few months ago,
I started doing animals I did them for a few days, but again, I wouldn't do coffee animals
necessarily on a regular basis if you're in full revision as far as cancer goes. Some people, you know,
understand the purpose of doing a coffee animal. So, the purpose of doing a coffee animal is to
stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system because it stimulates your vagus nerve, your
creatinial nerve, 10. So, vagal nerve stimulation stimulates your parasympathetic which helps stimulate
detoxification pathways and can stimulate immune function. So, you don't do a coffee animal because
your constipation, even though you can't do a coffee animal for constipation, but the purpose of doing
a coffee animal is to stimulate your parasympathetics. So, a person that has, it is prone to sympathetic
overdrive. So, remember, we're talking about sympathetic and parasympathetic. We're talking about
that balance in your autonomic nervous system. Your autonomic nervous system is your automatic
nervous system that is controlling everything in your body that you don't have to think about. So,
some people are prone to sympathetic overdrive. There can be chemical reasons for that.
The primary is excess glutamated, the brain, but that's another discussion. So, for
first, it is prone to sympathetic overdrive. Those are people that are more OCD, that are more
anxiety-ridden. Coffee animals on a daily basis, you know, even if they don't have any other
co-morbid health conditions can be extremely beneficial because they are colby because what do they
do? They stimulate your parasympathetics. So, people that are sympathetic, driven,
and tend to be imbalanced that way. Doing daily coffee animals can be fantastic for them,
and they just make them feel better. It takes away their anxiety. Why? Because it's stimulating
your parasympathetics. So, there's benefit to that. So, everybody's different. I have some patients
that never do coffee animals that you just don't want to do. And I have a lot of patients that do
them daily, even in full remission, that they're doing great. Okay, we have another question
that came in that was a rather long question. Hi there, I just read your page,
I understand the right frequencies, and it certainly shows a lot of many things and many treatments.
I benefited from right therapy over the past few years going, okay, so we'll go down. I have been
facing a systemic MRSA infection in NABX, failed to address biomedical staff members that failed
to perform adequate testing to diagnose. What I have certainly going on appears that to have
me from contaminated water supply here in Dallas, Texas. Yet, I'm having second thoughts. Now,
you mentioned your article, Frequency's Dude Diagnosis Disease. However, it does that also be the
Frequency's Diagnosis to eliminate pathogens to not determine the presence of those specific
catalysts. So, let me just answer that question, because I talk about in a lot of places that,
you know, there's those different apparatuses that different practitioners use. So, it's a little hand
cradle things to diagnose. So, it's running frequencies through your system, and it's getting feedback
of those frequencies, and that it tells the machine what frequencies that person got feedback on.
And often, those tools are used to diagnose, and I caution people to not do that, because
just because you had a hit on a certain frequency, doesn't mean that it doesn't mean that you have
that disease. Could it point to that possibly? Could it give you clues? Sure, but it doesn't mean that
you have that disease. So, I'm very outspoken against using frequencies to diagnose. You need to use
standard labs. You need to use standard proven therapies that could get to a diagnosis.
I'm not saying that you can't do those tools, and you can't use alternative things to give you
clues, to give you ideas, but I'd be very careful to not say, oh, you have, you know, mercury toxicity,
because it came back on your, forgot what those scans are, there's multiple different companies that
have those. It can give you ideas, but to say that you have mercury toxicity based on that scan,
I think that's not good science, and I, you know, wouldn't necessarily say it's malpractice,
but I'd say that's not good practice. And then this person is a very, very long question.
So, talking about H. Kylo right and Immerset infection, it's really asking for the best help you
could offer as it appears at both H. Kylo and Immerset have crossed the blood-brained barrier.
Okay, can bacteria cross the blood-brained barrier? Yes, absolutely. So,
even a healthy intact blood-brained barrier bacteria can get across, but certainly
there's probably very few people that have a healthy intact blood-brained barrier. Remember,
your blood-brained barrier is made up of certain glial cells called astrocytes that literally wrap
around the vessels that are going through the brain, protect it from bad guys, chemicals,
additives, you know, things that are certain in your blood, oxidizing agents, pathogens from
getting across. But things because we're exposed to so many toxins, those things can damage cells
in our body, in our blood-brained barrier, those astrocytes are not immune to damage, so they can be
damaged, and then you have, you know, gaps in your blood-brained barrier, and things get across
in the blood-brained barrier. That's been shown in proven time and time again that that takes place.
And remember, for children, that's why I'm so against vaccines for kids, is that, you know,
before age three, they don't have a blood-brained barrier, and it hasn't even formed yet. So,
anything gets across the blood-brained barrier because it's on there. So, but yes, pathogens,
MRSA, H. Pylori, certainly can get across the blood-brained barrier. H. Pylori,
when it goes systemic, is a major player for a lot of bad things to happen. So, that's why a big
fan of using products like Burberry, because Burberry is a great killer of H. Pylori.
Okay, so under the question, it is crucial that I know what needs to be done to fully resolve
this sooner or the later, as hours of treatment every day, only to a four-time cannot go on to
definitely. Please contact me if you want. Okay, you can call our office. So, anyway,
that it's on this call. You can contact our office. You can schedule directly without
contacting our office. We have a schedule now button. Let's go to that page and schedule a time
with me. And if you've never had time with me before, you have to start with what's called a case
review. And as many documents as that you could send to support your issues that you may have,
like pathology reports or blood tests and things that you've done recently can help you.
So, the more information that we have, the better that can be from where I can help you.
Okay, a couple other questions came in here. Okay, so this is a rife question. What is a testable
bulb for a rife machine? So, a Tesla bulb is just another name for a gas-filled tube. So, with
using rife frequencies, my definition of rife, because anybody can define it anyway,
they won't let it cause there's no standard. It's just using somebody's name. But my definition
of a rife machine is using light frequencies. And you use light frequencies through a frequency
generator by using a Tesla tube or a gas-filled tube, same thing. So, that's what it is. So,
with the true rife, which is the machine we use, you're using the bulbs that are all sealed
gas-filled tubes. So, the frequencies are going through there and you're getting the frequencies
through that light. So, that's what disperses is the light. So, it's not electrical frequencies.
It's light frequencies. And that's my definition of a rife machine.
Next question. How important is it to have a grounding sheet under your fitted sheet?
Well, the purpose of using a grounding sheet is to ground you to the ground. The purpose of
grounding is that we pick up positive charges from everything. I mean, I have radio waves going
through me right now. I have cell phone waves going through me right now. I can't see them, but they're
still affecting me. I mean, and those give me a positive charge. I don't mean positive like good
positive. I mean, positive like positive versus a negative charge as far as ionic goes. So,
I get that positive charge based upon everything that's going through me from an EMF electrical
frequency perspective. But I also get that from foods I eat from dirty electricity in my home
to everything. I'm sitting here in front of three computer screens. That's giving me that
positive charge. That's not necessarily good for us. So, when you go outside, the earth has a negative
charge. It has a stable negative charge. So, when I go outside and touch my hands or my feet to the
ground, then I'm dispersing that positive charge and balancing by cell charge to my body.
That's extremely healthful or we could say it's extremely unhealthy to not do that at different times.
That's why I'm very big into getting outside as much as you possibly can and touching the ground.
If I'm going outside and walking around with rubber shoes, I'm not grounded myself. However,
your pet is a great source of grounding. So, your pet is going outside presumably without boots on
and they are getting grounded. So, they're getting filled with nice negative ions in the
youth. They come in and you pet your dog and you're basically discharging your positive ions
onto your dog. Well, you're not going to hurt your dog. It's going to go outside to get a discharge
that outside. So, pets can help ground. But you could also ground through wires. So, a grounding
sheet is just a sheet full of small little interconnected wires that's then connected to your
house ground. You've got to make sure your outlets are all grounded. So, to your house ground,
it plugs into that bottom or depends on how you have your outlet set up. That one single thing
on the bottom of your ground outlet plugs into that. That goes back to a ground on your electrical
panel, which then hopefully is tied to a copper wire that goes outside, tied to a copper stake that
should be staked in the ground, you know, four or five, six feet. So, typically you buy those
at the hardware store. They're six feet long and you pound them into the ground. That's what grounds,
that's what grounds your electrical system in the house to protect it from shorts and things.
It's keeping it grounded. So, you're not getting this excess of charge build up in your wires.
That's called dirty electricity. You'll get dirty electricity spilling up in your house all the time.
The better your house is grounded, the less you'll have of that. Well, you could take advantage of
that system that you already have built into your house, hopefully. Though, I did go to a house once and
we tested their system. You can buy these little testing devices on Amazon that you could plug into
your, you could buy it at a hardware store that's only like five bucks or less. Plug into it out
that to see if it's properly grounded or not. It's not that you need to either do that or call
an electrician. I had a patient once that we went to their house. She was having all sorts of
issues. Went to her house, checked her out. That's just, she just had her house within the last couple
years. This she had an older house. She had a completely rewired by an electrician. He'd ever
connected any of the ground. So, get this early, trust your electrician, I guess. So, that was a
shallow, high opener. Every single outlet in their house though. It had those three little
prongs. They were grounded. None of the outlets were grounded. Pretty crazy. So, especially with new
construction, you just, you just don't know what's going on. So, you could get that checked really easy
with that little device that you just plug into the outlets. But then you can plug in a ground wire,
and then you could sit all day long on a grounded sheet or a grounded mat, and it's grounded you.
So, you're not going outside. So, there's huge benefits to that. Using a grounded sheet at night,
your grounded yourself all night long, and there's all sorts of evidence that it can help take away
aches and pains. It can help people sleep better, et cetera, et cetera. So, it's really beneficial to
be grounded. That's why I always suggest you go outside barefoot for the summertime and get
your feet toughened up so that you can best ground yourself, be outside, you know, touch the
environment, be interactive with your environment, work in the garden, touch the soil. That's all
your grounded yourself, and there's tons of evidence that makes you feel much better.
Okay, that is all the time we have for today. So, we are going to slide off. Thanks for joining us.
Remember, if you have questions, just go on our website, go to our holistic help live stream call.
You can put in your questions for that. That'll pretty much guarantee that we'll get those answered.
And if you have any desire to contact me or you have any personal questions,
you want to dig into or dig into your health, feel free to schedule a time with me too.
All right, God bless. Bye-bye.